was genau sagt die russische regierung
jetzt wo es diese befunde ganz klar ist
dass navalny vergiftet worden ist ja
also wir haben jetzt das sagt man als
strohfeuer von desinformation was man
aus dieser richtung leider schon kennt
von älteren fällen
ich erinnere nur an den fall scriba 2018
herr presskopf hat gestern also der
kreml sprecher putin-sprecher persönlich
also von höchster stelle hat gestern
abend gesagt der herner waren die wurde
überprüft das wurde medizin nicht
überprüft und als er russland verlassen
hatte hatte er noch kein gift im blut da
hat er den stopp gesagt hat wir arbeiten
gerne mit ihnen zusammen aber eins ist
klar wir haben ihn nicht vergiftet
sondern erst als er in berlin war hat
man gift festgestellt mehr hat er nicht
gesagt aber man weiß natürlich was
daraus schlussfolgert nämlich dass er
sagt wenn herr presskopf homo vergiftet
wurde
dann wurde in berlin vergiftet ganz
ähnlich hat sich der chefstratege von rt
deutsch vom russischen staates kanal hat
die deutsch geäußert auch der hat gesagt
die bundesregierung nicht etwa die
russische regierung die bundesregierung
jetzt dringend aufklären was passiert
ist in dem krankenwagen was passiert ist
in diesem bundeswehr labor und wie es
dort zu diesem befund von new york
gekommen ist das russische außenamt geht
da ein bisschen eine andere richtung
froh war dass die sprecherin des
außenamtes hat noch nichts davon gesagt
hat aber gesagt dass das ganze wir einen
plan aussieht denn die bundesregierung
lange vorbereitet hat wo man die kopien
nur aus dem schrank holen musste und
dann sozusagen auf knopfdruck eine
theorie hier
stichwort wieder skipper 2008 sind noch
mal wiederholen konnte hannah sie haben
gestern nachdem der befund dann an die
öffentlichkeit gekommen ist auf twitter
geschrieben ich kann nur hoffen dass
auch jetzt die letzten russland
versteher aufwachen der kreml schreckt
offenbar noch nicht einmal davor zurück
massenvernichtungswaffen gegen seine
kritiker im eigenen land einzusetzen
also im klartext was denken sie jetzt
darüber über diesen befund vor allem
über die kritik oder sogar diesen
vorwurf den russland jetzt nach
deutschland verweist was wir ganz klar
sagen müssen dass der kreml jetzt
erzählt ist ehrlich gesagt dummes zeug
die ergebnisse bei allen die diesen ja
mehrfach bestätigt als er wie hier in
berlin angekommen ist hat die charité
relativ kurz danach sagen können es gibt
eine hemmung eines enzyms das für den
stoffwechsel wichtig ist im körper auch
das mehrfach bestätigt und labor der
bundeswehr das institut für
pharmakologie und toxikologie
münchen die kennen sich eigentlich
deutschlandweit am besten mit chemischen
kampfstoffen aus die haben bestätigen
können sowohl über eine blutprobe als
auch über ein abstrich der haut der
genommen worden ist ist ein gift der
nord gruppe ist ein gift das
international geächtet ist auch russland
hat ein abkommen unterschrieben ende der
90er jahre das dieses gift verboten
gehört es ist ein gift es nur in
russischem besitz ist das muss man dazu
wissen also wer sonst sollte herr
navalny dieses gift verabreicht haben
wir reden hier beim klaren mordanschlag
und zwar mit einer waffe die
international verboten geächtet ist mit
massenvernichtungsmittel